here we go and
[Music]
asteroid City we wanted a slightly
exaggerated desert desert to set a play
I had a thought that we might find a
place that was very very flat and open
and build our rocks and build our town
the place where we filmed chinchon about
an hour from Madrid well if you want
flat land and you decide you want to
shoot in Europe I think you'll soon find
yourself in Spain quite a perfect spot
for us to do this and with the right
amount of room another 10 Paces forward
Sandy you see that wonderful crackly
patch right out there between the dead
cactuses and the dried up riverbed I
think so that's your parcel we laid it
out and we made miniature rocks and we
figured it out for the location we had
originally looked at locations
ultimately the more time we spent
looking at images of different places
the more I started to feel like I wanted
a bit of each rather than building it in
the real landscape to instead create a
bit of the landscape as part of the play
time line up single file lunch time
lunch time line up single file
my word it's hot asteroid City the town
itself slowly in the course of time Adam
stockhausen and I working together on
this I guess the thing was to try to
make buildings that were as evocative of
the time as we possibly could and it's
interesting they could be in the place
always needed to have a certain mystery
you know there's a freeway on-ramp there
that goes to Nowhere there's a crater on
the edge of the town and an observatory
and the various things we needed for our
story we built it all and the great
thing was that it was a place where we
could work with a very small group which
way did he go
well once it was built we could be a
tiny group in this what seemed like an
abandoned town we could golf cart
ourselves to the set every day and back
home and work just the way I like to
work which is the actors come to the set
ready to shoot already in costume and
there's no trailers and there's no
trucks anywhere that you can see them
and we can be a bit like a student film
so we were a student film on an enormous
giant set in the middle of Spain